alright so i am with two of my favorite
political comics Felicia Michaels and
jimmy dore most of you guys probably
recognize them from our old show but
they are new to the all-new ruben report
what do you think of this this the digs
come on out its you have a great
apartment pretty pretty sweet Jimmy we
have a jib there is a camera flying
around you love the jib I do love the
gym you want you want told me the comedy
is ninety percent chip ninety percent
jib and ten percent eyebrow-raising ah
alright well then we're in good shape so
what I wanted to start we're gonna do
all that's good so we're gonna do all
politics all right I brought you guys on
for politics I know you guys love
politics so unfortunately we have to
start with Donald Trump I hate that we
have to start this way but I feel that
we do because this is the thing that has
just consumed everything so i guess i'll
just open it sort of evenly what do you
make of this Trump madness you know the
thing that irritates me most about
Donald Trump is how all my liberal
friends are freaking out you know I mean
they're oh he's gonna get his hands on
the button nose all that kind of
rhetoric is it would you nut up the only
way he's gonna get his hands on the
button is if that's what his wife calls
his penis yeah it's just so crazy so you
don't think he's gonna become the
president you have no fears that this
actually could be legit well I I think
anything is possible I hope he doesn't
become president and I mean it's scary
the people that are attracted to him
that scares me you know that he gives a
voice to that that's frightening yeah so
we'll get to those people in a second
because I do want to talk about them but
the do you think this thing is real I've
been saying for months I think he's
going to do three debates and we've
already done two but I think he's going
to get two three he's still going to be
peaking in the in the rankings and then
he's going to say I moved the dial I'm
out and then he's going to be the attack
dog for whoever the nominee is that
that's my basic prediction you know I do
you think this is real i well I say what
you want about Donald Trump he does make
the racism run on time what I do
actually enjoy listen to Donald Trump's
piece is because every once in a while
you know I'm in the mood to watch a
Hitler documentary but I want to hear it
delivered by Gary
you see so that's why I'm really he's
part Hitler part Gary Busey that kind of
that kind of work um Donald Trump I
predicted he would go away he doesn't
really want to be president he doesn't
want Iran to do anything he doesn't want
to have to read up on anything he
doesn't want to have to learn anything
he doesn't want to have to but so is
that is that the craziest part of this
cuz did you see about a week ago he was
on this radio show you it and he asked
him the difference between Hamas and
Hezbollah anyone that knows anything
about world politics anything you don't
know a lot to know that these are very
different groups one is in Gaza one is
in Lebanon and Syria and he made it
sound like it was a gotcha question what
is that the genius of him to every he
turns everything into I you see what the
media's you were to be is that the real
genius of that's not the genius thing of
Donald Trump would tell you the jihad me
here's the thing i would think the
average American doesn't know the
difference between those two factions
and it's complicated and everything's
intertwined it's not a gotcha question
anyone who's running for office should
know those answers yeah and the fact
that he can just keep going at it and
going at it and not taking any
responsibility for what he doesn't know
that's frightening you know and that
people don't call him out more right so
all right so let's talk about the people
that you mentioned these people that are
digging this because I know you you rant
and rave about politics all the time you
hate the system right I i hate the
system and what I think people are
attracted to is that he's calling the
system out on their so should
we at least grant him that much that he
has you know when he in the first debate
when he said well I donated money to
Hillary so she showed up to my my
wedding like should we should give him a
little credit on that kind of thing
right yes he gets a little a little
credit on that but you said what the
genius of Donald Trump is is that the
genius is that he knows it appeal to
people who are not geniuses right right
so that's he's not appealing to smart
people just like Ben Carson right so ben
Carson also but I respect Ben Carson
more than I do Donald Trump and I don't
respect Ben respect Ben Carson it all
right well there you go so Trump c-
charity yes so I mean so what he's doing
is he's gaining more support ben Carson
ironically with racists
but not gaining support with other
neurosurgeons isn't that interesting yes
what right well first off just ben
Carson real quick I mean can a
neurosurgeon not believe in evolution
don't wouldn't that be a warrant to take
your license away the stuff that he says
he said a couple of weeks ago that the
number one killer of african-americans
are abortions and one of them when he
said that I literally was like our cops
giving abortions that's so crazy it is
so insane so what do we do with this
whole group I just said in the intro to
this thing that I went to the GOP debate
I talked to a couple of these guys I
think Kasich is sort of a decent guy I
think Marco Rubio is at least in the
right line of work even if I disagree
with him on a lot of stuff but what do
you think about Trump's place in this it
seems to me they all seem like children
that can't get there the attention of
their dad you know he seems to be dad
that's getting all the attention and the
kids can't well you know you go back to
his supporters Donald Trump's I mean
there for instance women are is like
when he said Carly fiorina's face you
can't have that face and then his poll
numbers went up with women who hate
themselves yeah so that's really what's
and so and a lot of people won't say
that the mainstream news media won't
call him racists they'll say his
controversial comments on immigration
and they won't call them fascist which
is exactly what this is what it looks
like right so their charismatic their
popular they demonize the Pima grants
and the people with no money and no
power as being the problem right there
over overly nativist their natural
enters strong and military so he's he's
got all those 14 hallmark of misogyny is
big in fascist regimes right and in
their culture and he's pushing the
massagin ISM right I don't know if
that's a word and that sounded like work
so it's amazing so but we can south side
here and I say it on my show that that
this is what fast that's people go well
how did hitler happen well he gave a
good speech he didn't have to appeal to
that many people and that's exactly what
Donald Trump is doing so that really is
so this is just a show right like to me
this is the ultimate reality show is
that at the end of the day is that
really what's happening here
yes I'm sorry we got his book the only
thing I want to say about when i watch
Donald Trump is the makeup that he has
on his face and I'm being completely
serious I just had three baby mamas they
all are all gorgeous women that know how
to apply makeup and the fact that he
doesn't turn to his wife or one of the
former baby mamas and go do you think
this is too much orange too much wine
under the ice says to me this is a
person that doesn't give a about
anyone else's opinion or doesn't care no
I'm sick oh yeah Lee seriously as a
silly woman that I am I'm all like
there's something wrong with that guy
that he can't turn to his woman and say
what do you think well you know what's
rubbing be able do that with any subject
he can't turn to his woman cuz she you
know his women are anchor wives I don't
last thought ID him I mean is there
something really psychologically sort of
void in someone that's answer to
everything is they love me and I'm gonna
show you why they I look forward to
Donald Trump's next speech where he
calls another group of people rapists
and then ends it with but they love it
but they love ya yeah exactly um all
right so let's move on to the other one
which the other big one which is Hillary
and to me it seems like Hillary is
running I think the worst campaign
probably in modern history forget the
email thing and the you know
inaccessibility of the press there seems
to be just know sort of joy or humanity
or sense of who she is or any of that
stuff are you guys with me on that what
do you think about the campaign itself
you're correct Dave it is horrible she's
at the beginning of the summer she said
that nobody stands up for progressive
values stronger than she does and then
just the other day she said hey I'm
eccentric she's bragging that she's
that's what's wrong with the country you
knucklehead is that we the center has
moved to the right so now when you say
you're a centrist you're actually a
Republican from the 90s right hey and
that's the problem so and that's why
Bernie Sanders has such traction and
that's why she's doing such a bad job
but I will say the the email thing it
just goes to prove you because they did
they just came out and said that there
was if you don't commit a crime it will
haunt you for the rest of you okay so
they've said so i guess the State
Department has said that she actually
didn't send any classified emails I
don't know what to believe at this point
but to me the whole thing is sort of
nonsensical because yes one day we're
just going to have a point where the
politicians just won't use email or they
won't use any electronic communication
and they're going to do all their bad
by just talking to people you know
you mean like so to make it about the
emails itself is sort of yeah it's the
March the wound not really what's what's
the underlying problem I don't think
necessarily that she's running a
terrible campaign it could be a lot
better yeah i think when we are talking
earlier in the green room and you were
saying what does she stand for I thought
that was a great point because no one
knows what does she specifically stand
for yeah I mean we know yeah what house
is very democratic but how would the
possible is one thing where you were
like what is Hillary like you can't name
one thing that she likes right so so I
think you generally you basically like
her right like like and I was telling
him earlier I have a picture of the gig
15 years ago of Hillary and me in the
backstage and I'm like I just want her
to be President for that picture I mean
that's a funny answer to the seriousness
of the question yeah the thing is she's
had so much bad news over the past two
or three months on headlines about
Benghazi all the time about those emails
and it's just insane how much people in
America don't want establishment
candidates and that's the problem with
her is she's too establishment you know
that's why Donald Trump is doing good
that's why Bernie Sanders is doing good
people want something different yeah so
I want to get to Bernie in a sec but I
think you hit on something with the with
the establishment and the media it seems
to me that the media loves Trump because
they because of what we said earlier
this off the prompter thing Hillary is
completely scripted and I also think the
media are sort of digging the fact that
Hillary's been around for so long and
it's she's always had this back and
forth with the media and I think they
love just attacking her that in no way
is a defense yes of her but how much is
just that the media just loves a
narrative and now it's like we're gonna
take down this woman yes that's that is
exactly what you know and I not that I
want to defend Hillary Clinton but you
know to be too you have to in this
situation because the New York Times
aside like a freakin vendetta against
her over these and the it would there
was nothing by the way you talk about
email Hank Paulson who was the secretary
of the Treasury when
everything went belly up right when the
whole thing cratered he never even used
emails right and that I use email right
so that's what your pointers is like
well let's make a bigger deal out of her
emails and no one will put anything in
an email that's important right and by
the way we know that even when you lie
under oath we've talked about this a
thousand times like James clapper who
was the head of the CIA and they they
asked him are we you know doing this
mass data collection and he said not
wittingly as he was scratching the top
of his head because that's where you
scratch when you're in your life liya so
we know that even when you lie right
like they're not going to really do
anything that makes me laugh because
Pottery Barn does mass data collection I
think everybody does they know what you
what you have in your kitchen they do
know what I have in my kitchen yeah all
right so let's move on to Bernie because
this is the one that I think we should
be talking about more and I've been
trying to talk about him more I think
he's talking about the right things
income inequality which was a huge
problem he's talking about money in
politics which nobody is talking about
as I told you guys earlier i went to the
GOP debate I literally think I might
have been the only person that asked
anyone in that room about money in
politics I asked Scott Walker he went
out of the race two days later I mean
that tells you something so that's what
that goes back to your earlier question
about Donald Trump deserves credit for
bringing up this issue yes he does
expose the Craven asst and the and the
emptiness of the political process right
or the I don't know the complete
corruption of the political process but
then no reporter ever says hey what's
your plan to fix that nobody ever says
hey that was great the way you showed
everybody how you buy all these guys on
stage what's your plan to fix that right
and he doesn't know so he's also at the
same time revealing the corruption in
the political process he's revealing the
corruption in the news media right so
the news beat Chuck Todd had him on and
he asked him the Muslim question right
and he started it out this is just
sunday and he said you know if you say
that you don't have to respond to
everybody who says something and i agree
with you on that that's how he started
his question so he just entered chuck
todd just interviewed Donald Trump after
the biggest you know gaffed you could
ever imagine right some guy says let's
call let's round up Muslims and by the
way the presidents of Muslim and Trump
says yes to both of them Chuck Todd the
number one political reporter in America
has him on a show doesn't lay a
glove on him yeah here you can curse
yeah let's delay and then he's like well
thanks for having and in Donald Trump
says there was a pleasure and you know
what Chuck Todd says you bet yeah that's
what he said so that's what's wrong with
the and if you see go why do we have the
biggest income disparity since the
Gilded Age why do we only have five
major media corporations in America when
there used to be 50 in 1980 why can't we
get this straight though why does it
when we nationalize the bank's nobody
calls it that and that's because they're
all bought and paid for by the same
people read manufacturing consent right
all right so I think your answer the
original question was what about Bernie
and I think you got there you know a
long way because he is talking about
those things yeah so basically do you
think that the media just has a vested
interest in really not showing him so
for example the other day Bernie and
Trump were both giving speeches at the
same time and even MSNBC which you'd
think would be and they're supposed to
lean forward or I guess they did until
two months ago now I don't now that they
lean backwards i'm not sure but even
they were covering Trump instead of
covering Bernie so can i Ken an outsider
like Bernie ever really win if he is a
little bit more fun I'm seriously the
answer why people love Trump because
he's fun yeah you can make fun of him it
doesn't hurt his feelings you know and
he is out of the box but when it comes
to Bernie like they they're gonna have
to start putting him on The Tonight Show
drinking wine with you know yeah yes
well I saw he did I did a promo he did a
promo for the nightly show and he said
on fleek which you've ever heard Bernie
Sanders say on fleek it was actually
pretty funny yeah um but yes so how much
of that is it that he's the outsider
guys so he should be getting the Obama
the first time Obama went around he
should be getting that excitement but
but Bernie himself he's a 70 something
year old white guy from Vermont mm-hmm
he's not that exciting and sad like home
yeah right there right like you should
shave the sides but but you know I
really like how much is just that that
maybe his person sadly in in 2015 in
America that his personality doesn't
match up in the way we want to vote for
somebody the way his rhetoric which I
think a lot of people agree with you
know it's funny that he's the big
outsider on the left and I'm Trump is
the big outsider on the right
and one of them spend zero time on their
hair and what about here I would like to
ask Donald Trump does he have a
long-form birth certificate for that
hairpiece anyway so that thing
definitely was not born in America know
what do you think you talk about what
you know so in even MSNBC wasn't
covering Bernie right well it's because
MSNBC is not a liberal corporation their
incorporation by the way through the
whole Iraq war MSNBC was owned by
General Electric which is a huge defense
contractor so the lefties were left
getting their anti-war message from a
defense contractor which is why
they fired Phil Donahue because he was
against the war and they kept Chris
Matthews and then they also just fired
Ed Schultz because he's against the TPT
and comcast is all for the TPT so I said
I always said this but they're not
liberal the suit is Rachel Maddow says
something that cost Comcast's money they
will fire her and it's just an
embarrassment to her that they haven't
well for the record or has told me I can
say anything I want a pencil that's
pretty good that's pretty good i mean it
should be the embarrassment to them and
if you watch the channel like i do you
see that they're corporatists they're
not especially chris hayes he's couldn't
be worse yeah all right so my last
thought on this is does he have any
chance does Bernie have any chance my
feeling is no unfortunately and I know
people are gonna give me for saying
that cuz if they'll they'll say to me if
you say no that causes people to get ya
rest about it and then they're not going
to vote I just unfortunately I think
that it's very clear to me that the
party is going to not going to back him
they simply will not back in and that's
why people are talking about Biden
because I think Hillary probably will
flame out and they're gonna go with
Biden and it's like you guys are the big
party the only loss our base minorities
and women and everything else and we're
gonna pick the VP who's just another old
like why don't embrace burn is because
he isn't independent and he railed so
hard against both Democrats and
Republicans won't win I think he they
think he can't that a liberal from
someone that far on the left from the
Northeast just can't win the middle of
the country I think that bring us home
no I think the reason why the democratic
party hasn't rallied around bernie is
because the he's not in bed with the
big-money donors and so they report the
democratic party no longer responds to
their voters they only respond to their
donors and so their donors are telling
them get rid of this guy right we got to
get rid of that guy
how they don't want the donors want
nothing to do with Bernie because they
can't control them just like the donors
don't want anything to do with Donald
Trump because they can't control him so
in that sense they're very much alike
and that's exactly what's happening we
do live in a banana republic what we
don't really have a responsive
government i mean the Sandy Hook taught
us anything ninety percent of people in
America wanted some kind of gun
legislation and we didn't get it so I'll
no longer do our representatives
represent our interests they only
represent the donors and that's why
Bernie's winning and that's why he gets
30,000 people when he shows up to speak
that's how you end assay
[Music]